c'est une caméra cachée qui a fait près
de 9 millions de vues dans un parc
londonien le nomme maltraite sa
conjointe qui te compter sur
l'intervention des passants mais plus
tard lorsque les rôles s'inversent
l'homme ne récolte que l'indifférence
voire les moqueries
c'est pourtant une scène beaucoup plus
courantes que l'on pourrait le croire
soixante dix mille hommes sont victimes
de violences conjugales en france les
femmes sont incontestablement plus
exposés aux violences les plus graves
mais les hommes violentés existe seuls 3
% d'entre eux devraient se tourner vers
la justice quitte l'as souvent les
plaintes sans suite
la martinique ne fait pas exception nous
des hommes quand même nous avons quand
même certaines fientes et y en a
d'autres qui ne veulent pas en parler
donc même si que s'il aura meilleur ami
ils ne vont jamais en discuter
enfin mon café de méchanceté mais ça bat
k -o par défaut de nom alors la gauche
se cacher nous rabat 12 hommes et 12
secondes il a remis ça c'est leur
problème
il a mûri tu le mérites oui comme la
femme est battue alors il faut craindre
aussi la femme attend les hommes je
pense qu'ils sont trop orgueilleux pour
pour se dénoncer
donc ils ne le disent pas tout
simplement il ya des hommes battus ça
existe dans une société où l'homme est
éduqué dans l'idée de la virilité voire
de la domination
le tabou est encore plus grand le schéma
social est à sens unique
l'homme ne peut être que l'agresseur
violent et la femme la victime opprimés
c'est une blessure qui l'ont vécue alors
qu'ils ressentent eux comme une
humiliation qui vient en décalage par
rapport aux représentations qu'ils
avaient où l'homme devrait être celui
qui domine et là il domine non seulement
pas la situation mais en plus ils n'y
arrivent pas à se protéger et le vit
souvent avec un sentiment de honte de
trois quarts des personnes qui se
suicident sont des hommes on sait très
bien que le suicide survient avec
différentes causes que les conflits
conjugaux affectifs sont des facteurs de
risque majeurs à de comportements
suicidaires
le suicide il y as pensé plusieurs fois
du haut de ses 1 m 84
maxime gaget porte encore les stigmates
de la maltraitance jusque dans sa
démarche
tout commence en 2007 quand il emménage
avec une femme et ses deux enfants
très vite c'est l' escalade jusqu'à la
torture et la barbarie où la
séquestration véritable cauchemar par
rapport aux violences psychologiques
part d'audience physique
c'est un ensemble réussi à entrer dans
mon esprit un chemin de votre cycle peur
panique ça a été par exemple du gros sel
dans les yeux ce qui est décent
dangereux ça a été un gestion forcé
produits chimiques
ça a été des blessures diverses sur
jeanne encore des marques surtout
l'épiderme
la seule chose qui m'a été donnée de
pouvoir demander a été simple pourquoi
est elle va me fournir une réponse qui
va être un selon la même tout du long
à savoir si qu'il ne m'avait pas exciter
ça ne serait jamais arrivé donc il ya un
premier report de ses propres erreurs
sur moi si j'avais commis l'erreur de
riposter à la violence par la violence
j'aurais inévitablement
laisser des marques ont de par mon
gabarit et les à la force physique que
je possède
et cette dernière serait immédiatement
allé au poste de police pour déposer
plainte après violences conjugales et
dans l'eure qui aurait suffi je sors est
reparti avec le 2e bracelet en acier
trempé
dix ans après avoir été défigurée et
frôlé la mort maxime gaget qui a
condensé son calvaire de nant dans un
livre refuse d'opposer les hommes et les
femmes
il n'y a pas à faire c'est cloisonnement
et cette opposition des genres qui est
fait sur un plan sur un plan b des
titres encore politique
la situation est beaucoup plus globale
qui me paraît il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
que des femmes victimes mais aussi des
hommes qui d'ailleurs malheureusement
sont réduits au silence ou se mure dans
le silence et en partie leur fierté tous
l'importance véritablement capital de
pouvoir parler pour que toutes ces
victimes se fassent connaître
et plus il y aura de personnes qui
parleront par rapport à cela
plus vite les auteurs seront
neutralisées l'ex-compagne de maxime
gaget a finalement écopé de deux ans
prison ferme et d'une lourde amende
aucun martinique et n'a accepté à ce
jour de témoigner anonymement devant
notre caméra
[Musique]